For years scientists believed that
the brain was static, unchanging and locked.
But our understanding has changed drastically to
the point where we now see the brain as
plastic and constantly changing.  But what
if I told you that simply thinking could
affect not only the way your brain works
but its physical shape and structure as
well?
It turns out this is exactly what
happens.  From a neuroscientific
standpoint imagining an action and doing
it require the same motor and sensory
programs in the brain.  For example, if you
were to close your eyes and imagine the
letter "B" the primary visual cortex
lights up in the same way it does when you
look at the letter on the screen.  Take a
moment and imagine yourself writing out
your signature with your dominant hand.
Chances are the amount of time it takes
you to simply imagine doing it is
similar to how long it actually takes to
write it out. Try doing the same thing
with your non dominant hand and it
actually takes you longer to write and
imagine.
How is this relevant?
Well because imagination and action are
actually integrated and engage the same
neural pathways, practicing one actually
influences the other.
One fascinating study took two groups
and had them practice piano for two
hours a day.
Except one group was only allowed to use
mental practice, they couldn't touch the
piano but would sit in front of it and
imagine practicing. The surprising result,
the exact same physical changes took
place in the motor cortex of both groups.
And after three days their accuracy in
playing was the exact same,
beyond five days the physical
practice group did begin to excel faster
but the imagination group, when given the
chance to practice physically, was able
to catch up to their skill level quickly.
Perhaps more incredible is an experiment
which used imagination in an effort to
strengthen muscles.  Both groups did the
same figure muscle exercises for four
weeks
though one group simply did it mentally.
Those who actually did the physical
exercise increased their strength by
thirty percent while those who imagined
doing it increased their muscle
strength by twenty two percent.
This is because the neurons responsible
for the movement instruction were still
being used and strengthened, resulting in
increased strength when the muscles
actually contracted.  So while your
thoughts don't have some mystical or
magical power, mental practice is an
effective way to prepare for a physical
skill.  Each thought actually changes the
structure and function of your brain by
affecting the neurons at the microscopic
level.
Though as much as we wish you could sit
there and become the next Mozart, it won't
happen without a lot of hard physical
work, but a little imagination never hurts.
This episode of a AsapSCIENCE is supported by
audible.com, the leading provider of
audio books, with over one hundred
thousand downloadable titles across all
types of literature.  This episode was
inspired by the book "The Brain That
Changes Itself" by Norman Doidge.  You can
download this audiobook or another of
your choice for free at audible.com/asap.
Special thanks to audible for making
these videos possible and offering you a
free audio book at audible.com/asap, and subscribe for more weekly
science videos.